now our father is making a desperate
appeal for people from
ethnic minority backgrounds to join the
stem cell donor register
it's in the hope of finding a match for
his 12 year old daughter who was
diagnosed with a rare blood disease
in july of this year joined now by the
surgeon
garrett lloyd and his daughter aria
hello to you both thank you for joining
us
this morning um guaranty if i could talk
to you
first of all um tell me a little bit
more about
aria's condition and what you're hoping
to achieve
yes so arya became unwell around july
with abdominal pain and she was pale and
not not quite herself
and we took her to the doctor and she
had a number of investigations
and her blood tests showed her full
blood count was abnormal with a low
hemoglobin
and a low platelet count of a low white
cell count meaning that she was at risk
of infection
and bleeding if she fell over or injured
herself
and she was referred to saint mary's
hospital in paddington
and had a bone marrow biopsy that showed
her bone marrow isn't functioning
properly
and she has something called aplastic
anemia
which is a rare and very serious bone
marrow failure condition
so at the moment a bone marrow isn't
producing the cells
that it needs to
and arya can't very good morning young
lady
good morning um
how are you feeling i'm feeling all
right but it's
it's very unusual um it's not the sort
of thing i'd expect to happen
to anyone especially me um
i mean before i was playing sports going
to school chilling with my friends
and then now i can't do any of that due
to my condition
which is quite annoying but um
it happens i guess
and so dad um she is being very
philosophical
but um what can people listening this
morning
and watching you both potentially do to
try to help
yes she's been very very brave about it
um it's had a
massive impact um she can't go to school
she's shielding
and we need to find a match it's the
only cure for a aplastic anemia is a
stem cell match
and a stem cell um transplant so
what we're doing is trying to encourage
as many people as possible to come
forward
and join the stem cell register and it's
a really easy thing to do
at the moment about two percent of the
population in britain is on stem cell
register
and there are two organizations um who
are both great anthony nolan
and dkms and you can register to join
the stem cell register on either of
their websites
you click on a link um they go to a
number of questions
send a kit and you take a mouth swap
which you you send back
and you're on the register the issue
we have and a lot of other people have
is that it's very difficult to get a
stem cell match if you're
from an ethnic minority or mixed
background
if you're of white north european origin
there's about a 70
chance of getting a match but with
ethnic minority or mixed backgrounds
there's about a 20
or lower chance of getting a match so
we're really appealing for people
of indian or mixed indian caucasian
origin to come forward and join the
register
to help aria and many thousands of
people just like her
who are really struggling to get the
match
and aria what are you most looking
forward to doing when you're better
again
um seeing my friends going to school
doing sports
um and just getting back to the normal
life i guess
normal i think yeah what does your life
mean to you going to see your friends at
school and
playing outside and and generally doing
what 12 year olds do i suppose
yeah okay
well i hope that happens very soon
indeed for you
young lady and and dad thanks so much
for taking the time to join us
this morning appreciate you doing that